et pour revenir sur cette crise du
coronavirus et des mesures déployées par
le gouvernement nous sommes en direct
avec anthony cahier secrétaire du
syndicat cgt police bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
on a tous entendu à l'allocution du chef
de l'état hier soir puis les mesures qui
ont été détaillées par le ministre de
l'intérieur christophe castaner
concernant la réduction des déplacements
pour les français avec des restrictions
alors concrètement du côté de la police
comment cela va se matérialiser sur le
terrain à l'écouté pour l'instant les
consignes sont assez claires le ministre
a précisé
effectivement qu'il faudrait procéder à
des contrôles des riverains et des
citoyens et des gentils serait appelé à
se déplacer
la difficulté est là réside en fait dans
le fait d'organiser cette police qui
aujourd'hui subi également aussi elle
des mesures de confinement du virus
alors cent mille policiers et gendarmes
vont être déployés sur l'ensemble de
l'hexagone quels sont les justifient les
justificatifs pardon que vous allez
demander obligatoirement lorsqu'il ya
alors ce qu'il y aura des contrôles
justement je pense pour l'instant au
nombre de 200 me justificatif sera
effectivement la promesse d'attestation
qui est téléchargeable sur tous les
sites du gouvernement
c'est également une attestation qui peut
être faite manuscrite et puis le double
contrôle sera bien évidemment une quasi
nantais ont parlé de sanctions
financières une amende de 38 euros qui
devrait passer à 135 euros 1 selon le
ministre de l'intérieur c'est ce que
vous risquez
justement de faire de sanctionner les
passants qui serait là sans documents
qui les autorise à circuler alors
effectivement si vous trouvez en dehors
des des fameux 10 thèmes cités qui en
compte et précisés par le ministre de
l'intérieur
hier soir effectivement vous êtes
passible d'une amende de 35 euros
a priori du gouvernement voudrait
légiférer rapidement pour mettre en
place une un décret qui permettrait de
passer cette amende de 35 euros à 130
euros
certaines personnes sont autorisés à se
déplacer avec leurs justificatifs aussi
de travail ont pas on pense par exemple
à notre profession les journalistes avec
la carte de presse qui pourront circuler
mais les français qui auront besoin
justement d'aller au supermarché ou même
dash est juste une baguette de pain ils
devront présenter et justement ce
document c'est incontournable c'est
obligatoire puis le ministre a été clair
hier sur les mesures effectivement de
confinement chose que le président de la
république n'avait pas n'avait pa ti
dans son allocution le ministre a pris 1
lui quant à lui expliqué que c'était
bien une mesure de confinement et donc
il faudra effectivement présenté ces
tests cette attestation à chaque
contrôle de de gaulle historique vous
serez donc en première ligne sur le
terrain est ce que vous serez également
protégé on pense justement à à ces
mesures barrières on parle de masque on
parle de gel est-ce que vous aurez une
aide par rapport à ça alors c'est ce que
je vous disais dans mon propos liminaire
c'est toute la difficulté aujourd'hui
puisque les policiers sont aussi sujets
à des symptômes et sont aussi font aussi
l'objet de mesures de confinement
nous commençons effectivement recevoir
des masques et des produits hydro
alcooliques
on pense que c'est assez tardif
on aurait pu lire savoir bien avant mais
effectivement ça va être ça c'est l'une
des problématiques mais pour l'ensemble
des personnels je pense qu'ils seront
amenés à travailler fortement la nature
je pense aussi le personnel soignant a
très bien en tout cas merci beaucoup
anthony cahier d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire du syndicat cgt police